[Música]
en esto el escuela en el que yo me formé
norberto bobbio en italia el derecho y
el poder son las dos caras de una misma
moneda que no se puede entender el uno
sin el otro
el hecho sin poder es simplemente de
buenas intenciones son promesas es una
soplete de edición
que nos gustaría y nos desearía que
sucediera el que hace que el derecho sea
efectivo y encontrará el poder sin el
derecho es simplemente fuerza violencia
pura lo que doméstica al poder es el
derecho y en ese sentido tiene mucho
sentido preguntarnos cómo funciona la
relación de las constituciones y que son
las constituciones en los estados
contemporáneos y las constituciones los
políticos
en una coyuntura que tienen sin imponer
un institucional a la comunidad para la
sociedad que regir
desde ese punto de vista la constitución
es expresión del poder que fue el caso
de la constitución mexicana de 1917
al final un acotado entre un grupo de
revolucionarios que habían prevalecido
el gesta de inicios de siglo
pero también hay otras constituciones y
es desde la perspectiva del derecho las
constituciones son normas jurídicas
conducción normativa del pacto político
de esas fuerzas a las que hice
referencia y en ese sentido las
constituciones contienen al menos lo
siguiente tienen los principios que le
dan identidad a un estado
oleson de cada estado sino al artículo
40 de la constitución mexicana vigente
al día de hoy veremos que dice que es
voluntad nuestra constituir nos en una
república federal
representativa de ética y democrática si
metemos en cambio por ejemplo la
constitución argentina vigente el día de
hoy en su artículo 2º dice que el
gobierno de esa nación sostiene el culto
católico apostólico y romano son
identidades constitucionales distintas
los principios que le dan a una
comunidad política un sentido de
pertenencia compartido
otra cosa que sostienen las
constituciones que contienen
la relación entre nosotras y nosotros
entre los ciudadanos son reglas
dos cotidianos de convivencia entre
nosotros y muy importantísimo
entre los ciudadanos y sus propiedades
entre el gobierno y las personas que
habitan un territorio determinado y
finalmente constituciones también
contienen les lo el acuerdo la relación
que tienen los poderes entre sí mismos y
en ese sentido como conjunto normativo
constitucional e identidad una comunidad
de sentido de pertenencia a la
ciudadanía le dan sentido de convivencia
a los ciudadanos y dan un arreglo
institucional en los estados
constitucionales y esto no es nuevo
en el artículo 16 de la declaración
francesa de 1789 decimos que la sociedad
es que tienen constitución y que ellas
en las que los derechos reconocidos y la
división de los poderes está garantizada
yo sé quién
de ustedes
este que todos nosotros estamos
ejerciendo nos nos déjenme decirlo así
hechos fundamentales
yo estoy ejerciendo mi derecho de
libertad de expresión
nadie me dijo que tengo que decir y no
permitiría que nadie me lo dijera usted
de alguna manera están ejerciendo el
derecho a la información y quienes sean
estudiantes también el derecho a la
educación
y todos juntos aquí estamos ejerciendo
el derecho de reunión un derecho que no
les gusta a los estados autoritarios y
quienes trabajen en el inacipe y están
aquí no porque quisieron venir sino
porque pues tienen que venir están
ejerciendo su derecho al trabajo
así es no están por voluntad propia y un
derecho detrás de la razón por la que se
encuentran presentes el día de hoy
sus ejemplos de derechos pero de más
ejemplos de derechos vinculados al
sentido práctico de que es la agenda de
los derechos
hace muchos años me ha interesado en los
derechos humanos
y digo sí yo soy un académico derecho un
manero estoy convencido de que eso
importa
o que algunas gentes me ven con
escepticismo
otras me ven como si en mi espíritu
viera una suerte de espíritu cursi bien
intencionado ingenuo y la verdad es que
eso es un error
los que nos dedicamos a estudiar los
derechos humanos somos en verdad los
desencantados
somos los que sabemos el daño que somos
capaces de producir nos unos seres
humanos a otros y entendemos por qué es
importante que la igualdad la dignidad
la integridad personal la libertad y así
sucesivamente estén plasmados en los
pactos políticos constitucionales y que
sean las reglas que le dan identidad a
una comunidad y que le establecen los
límites al poder
y quiero ir el tema medular de esta
breve charla con ustedes
los derechos y la división de los
poderes y arreglos institucionales que
lo que pretenden buscan y persiguen es
limitar al poder
porque esto lo enseño maquiavelo el que
tiene poder tiende a aumentarlo y a
concentrar lo saben quien quien sean
ustedes
si les dan poder saben que van a creer
y más poder y más tiempo
y en esa lógica que no tiene nada que
ver con un prejuicio hacia los políticos
tiene que ver con una realidad de la
naturaleza y de la condición humana
pero tenía tiene este estupendo ensayo
de la política como vocación
en el que dice quien pretenda que los
políticos se guían por buenas
intenciones simplemente no ha entendido
la lógica de la política
la lógica de la política y del poder
va orientada a la concentración y a la
conservación del poder
muy bien las constituciones los derechos
la división de los poderes están
pensados y diseñados el kubra 2 e
implementados para limitar al poder
para evitar que quien lo tiene
se quede en el poder y que quien lo
detenta abuse del poder esa es la lógica
y son quienes se dedican al derecho
constitucional seriamente
desconfían del poder
lo que hacemos es imponerles reglas
diques controles límites los poderosos y
ese es nuestra función social académica
e institucional
en la pregunta si son hechos y si la
división de poderes la esencia de los
acuerdos constitucionales es posible que
existan reformas a una constitución que
sean contrarias con la propia
constitución es decir
reformar una constitución esta
constitución y son distintas pensemos en
la mexicana nuestro artículo que
establece la fórmula de reforma
constitucional 135 te dice lo que
requieres es una iniciativa puede venir
del ejecutivo o de otros actores pero el
ejecutivo siempre va a ser importante en
un sistema presidencial el ejecutivo es
el presidente de la república en méxico
han sido todos solamente presidentes
hasta el día de hoy
una iniciativa
hipias calificadas en una de las cámaras
méxico tiene como ustedes saben un
sistema bicameral diputados senadores o
viceversa
se requiere que la mayoría calificada de
los presentes a la iniciativa
presidencial y posteriormente es
necesario como sucedió ayer con la
reforma educativa que el menos la mitad
más uno de las legislaturas de las
entidades federativas porque méxico es
un estado federal prevén la reforma
constitucional si se logra la reforma
constitucional desde un punto de vista
formal es válida
es impecable es y jurídicamente hablando
que quiere decir que si un presidente la
república tiene mayoría en la cámara
diputados tiene mayoría en el senado y
tiene mayoría en los congresos de al
menos la mitad más uno las entidades
federativas e impulsar una reforma
constitucional
quién sabe
la pregunta es si esa reforma que viene
de un perro
y que sea el poder en méxico es
democráticamente electo de ojo que es
legítimo que se inventó su legitimidad
que es poder político la pregunta es si
una reforma impulsada desde ese poder
puede eventualmente contradecir el
sentido
fondo del acto y del acuerdo
constitucional y si entonces si
eventualmente sucediera
cuándo
el judicial
que puede
velar por que esa reforma política la
constitución política prevalezca
jurídicamente porque como dice el
sentido profundo del acuerdo
constitucional
es una buena pregunta y es un buen
dilema es un dilema que a nivel nacional
y que también puede trasladarse a nivel
internacional y preguntarnos y si la
corte falla
y si hay una reforma cuyo contenido es
claramente contradictorio electos de la
constitución y que el impulso el poder
político y después el poder judicial fue
miso en revisar la es posible que un
tribunal internacional intervenga y te
diga esa reforma que ahí se aprobó no es
compatible con el pacto constitucional
son preguntas relevantes y con dos
ejemplos nacionales y uno internacional
para concluir en los que esto puede
materializarse en los sueños del
presidente felipe calderón había una
figura en el código penal era que eran
aquí en el inacipe lo sabe muy bien el
arraigo suprema corte de justicia en la
nación dijo que esa figura que estaba en
una ley secundaria no en la constitución
era inconstitucional también que hizo el
poder político presidente congreso
etcétera etcétera
la constitución y dijo akon que era
constitucional pues ya no es
inconstitucional porque ya es
constitución
mente el mismo intento hacer el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
con la creación de la guardia nacional
me dicen que una red de seguridad
pública en el que los militares tienen
el mando no es compatible con la
constitución reformó la constitución
es decir la constitución se puede volver
la base para medir si una reforma por
debajo de ella es compatible con la
misma también se puede volver el cajón
de sastre en el que subes todo aquello
que quieres blindar contra el control de
los jueces
pregunta debe hacer la misma
constitución que es una suerte de
secuestro institucionalizado que
investigó detenido tengo que investigar
te no porque te investiguen o si son una
figura como la guardia nacional que es
incompatible las disposiciones de la
constitución como mismo arraigo por
ejemplo con el principio presunción de
inocencia que está en la constitución si
los la constitución es posible que esas
normas revisadas por una autoridad
judicial nacional o internacional
creo que sí
y menos la corte interamericana de los
derechos humanos ha tomado decisiones en
esa dirección les cuento una y concluyó
chile
la última tentación de cristo'
alguien vio esa película si no lo ha
hecho vea
censurada por el estado chileno primero
por el gobierno y después aunque fue
avalada por el poder judicial se mantuvo
la prohibición y la película durante
mucho tiempo no pudo ser transmitida por
las razones que ustedes quieran
el caso llegó a la corte interamericana
de los derechos humanos y la corte
interamericana de no al estado chileno y
libro de no entre otras cosas que
modifica su constitución que aquellas
normas que limita tibás de la libertad
de expresión y el derecho a la
información
modificadas porque resulta que esas
normas aunque estaban en la constitución
eran inconstitucionales muchas gracias
[Aplausos]